so last week we had a big discussion
across multiple days about should
progressives just now at this point work
to kill the spending and infrastructure
bill that's been completely gutted i
gave you a list last week of
five six major pieces of the proposals
that had been floating around that are
believed to be completely dead in the
water and i said at this point i'm okay
with progressive saying kill it
i often
say if it does some good then it should
be supported because it's a step in the
right direction it will help some people
and any opportunity to help people
should be taken
uh i started to go in the direction last
week of there's so little here that this
will serve as a victory for centrist
democrats by saying we don't have to do
anything progressives want it will serve
as a victory for republicans for saying
the more we obstruct the less they're
going to get even if we're not in
control and it's nothing for
progressives we've got a voicemail
related to killing the bill which i'm
going to play for you in a little bit
one bit of news is that bernie sanders
has not given up uh senator bernie
sanders appeared on cnn yesterday
and made it very clear that he's still
pushing at least to get lower drug
prices into the bill now if he was able
to do that is lower drug prices price
controls on on medications and
prescriptions would that be enough to
say well okay just for that alone
progressives should support it we'll get
to that in a second let's first listen
to some of this interview he gave you
have said there are major gaps in this
plan several several of your priorities
paid leave
dental and vision for medicare giving
the government power to negotiate lower
prescription drug prices for seniors
that's not in the deal uh you saw that
house progression
endorsed the compromise do you
well it's not in the bill yet but what i
can tell you donna we are working right
now i spent
all of yesterday on the telephone look
we are paying the highest prices in the
world
for prescription drugs
uh the pharmaceutical industry has spent
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars to make certain that americans
pay ten times more for some drugs than
the canadians or the mexicans do that
fight continues
uh and the fight to expand medicare look
poll after poll shows that the american
people understand it is not acceptable
that elderly people have teeth in their
mouth that are rotting they can't digest
their food
they can't they don't have the vision
that they need in order to read a
newspaper so we are continuing that
effort so can i just pains me very much
i'm sorry go ahead no i just want to
just make sure that i understand what
you're saying you're saying you're
continuing that effort you want to still
add it before the house votes you want
to add it to the the bill that
absolutely
look uh we're working as everybody
should know we're on two separate bills
you got a bipartisan infrastructure bill
which will finally begin to address the
reality that our roads and our bridges
and our water systems are crumbling
that's one bill but we want to move both
bills in tandem and the second bill the
bill that deals with the needs of the
working class of this country in terms
of childcare in terms of pre-k that
deals with the existential threat of
climate that bill is still being worked
on literally today it will be worked on
tomorrow i believe we're making some
progress in making it even stronger than
it is
if it if you don't succeed in that
progress
will you support the the framework as it
currently stands
what the white house released at the end
of the week
well
all i will tell you is we have a very
very strong bill
and it deals with uh the fact that uh we
are going to start paying attention to
the needs of working parents continue
that 300 we're going to build affordable
housing uh we're going to make sure that
elderly people and people with
disabilities can stay at home rather
than be forced so bernie goes into talk
you know these are these are talking
points that we've heard before but so
the fundamental question ultimately gets
to let's say bernie and other democrats
get lower prescription drug price
provisions into the bill then
should progressives support it
in my mind
that actually would be enough to say
support the bill
and it wouldn't change the fact that it
would still be missing and lacking so
many things that were talked about early
uh a tax that target you know between
these two bills tax that targets the
very very richest billionaires uh paid
leave child care you know there's so
medicare expansion so many things that
i'm in favor of and that are good and
that are necessary and that should be in
there um all of those things would still
be gone but the degree to which the
american people are getting screwed when
it comes to prescription drug costs and
it's so popular to talk about lowering
prescription drug costs both democrats
and republicans talk about it all the
time trump talked about it he didn't do
it
um but the mechanisms through which they
would do it of course differ there's no
question about that
um it actually would be so materially
useful to so many people particularly
seniors the way that bernie sanders is
talking about because of how medicare
works
that again i'm talking pragmatically i
know the optics are terrible but that is
so good for so many people that i would
probably say don't kill the bill
get the bill done if that's in there now
how likely that is to happen and how
much of this is bernie either posturing
or trying to put public pressure on uh
colleagues and other we just don't know
we just these negotiations are happening
constantly between different parties and
this is why my coverage of this has
basically been listen the entire process
is a grandstanding quagmire there's a
lot of this that is just the worst of
politics and worst of the dc beltway it
doesn't relate to people who are just
trying to afford gas trying to afford
food trying to afford medication it just
it doesn't connect this it's so abstract
and and uh uh um idealized in some way
by those who think oh big negotiate it's
it's a lot of bs that's going on and i
get all of that
but if there's really going to be
something actually done and if you trust
bernie if you're a bernie supporter if
you believe bernie does the right things
or tries to
then you would imagine that if he gets
that into the bill it's going to be
materially substantive i think i'm
probably back on and say just just pass
it and get it done and then let's move
on and try to do more and do the next
iteration if you disagree with me on the
value of a prescription drug price
controls as reason alone to support the
bill i want to hear from you reasonable
people can disagree but it seems like an
important thing to me